Bonjour tout le monde, on se retrouve pour un nouveau podcast, alors c'est un
peu particulier
puisque pour ce podcast on va être deux, et Justine en même temps est en train
de faire
des petits accessoires pour les conventions, pour vendre, c'est des petits
porte-clés
en pâte-fimo.
Pâte polymère.
Pardon.
Ça marche aussi.
Mais du coup aujourd'hui on va faire le podcast à deux parce qu'on va parler de
Émilie
in Paris et tout simplement parce qu'on a regardé la série ensemble et on l'a
fini
récemment, on l'a fini la semaine dernière.
Ouais, début de semaine.
Et du coup je voulais parler de cette série parce que c'est sûrement une des
séries
les plus populaires sur la France et qui a fait plutôt débat en France, je sais
pas
trop à l'étranger.
Mais voilà, c'est un peu quand on pense à la France, maintenant on a vite Émilie
in Paris qui vient en tête.
Qu'est-ce que je voulais dire ?
Oui, du coup, grosso modo on va parler de la série, on va dire ce qu'on en a
pensé.
Et en fait c'est un peu bizarre, mais j'avais plutôt le sentiment avant de
regarder la
série que les Français de manière générale avaient un avis négatif sur la série.
Moi je me rappelle avant d'avoir commencé à regarder la série, avoir en tête une
sorte d'idée qui disait toutes façons c'est des Américains qui parlent de la
France, ça
ne va pas être la réalité.
Toi t'avais un peu ça ou c'était une série que tu avais envie de regarder depuis
longtemps ?
Moi j'avais dû voir des avis négatifs, mais c'était il y a longtemps parce que
c'est
sorti quand même il y a quelques années, le début, et je pensais que ça allait
être
cul-cul, moi je m'attendais plus à un truc comme ça et c'est plus moi qui me suis
fait
Donc cul-cul c'est une expression pour dire trop romantique en fait, enfin too
much, un
peu comme les feux de l'amour à l'eau de rose, oui, une romance à l'eau de rose.
Et du coup tu pensais que ça allait être un peu ça, un peu too much, en soi
c'est
un peu cul-cul.
Oui mais je ne sais pas si on peut tout de suite parler.
Mais du coup, est-ce que tu avais déjà entendu un peu les avis négatifs ? Enfin
je ne sais
pas mais sur les réseaux sociaux par exemple, non vas-y vas-y.
Non moi le seul truc que j'ai cru voir, parce que ça remonte à longtemps, c'est
plus en
mode, parce que c'est pas sur la France, c'est sur Paris, c'était plus en mode,
c'est
pas comme ça Paris dans la vraie vie, plus des trucs comme ça parce que c'est
plus
romancé dans la série parce qu'elle a de l'argent, enfin voilà elle rencontre
vite du monde.
Elle trouve un appart grand pour Paris, et en fait, oui, c'est sa boîte, mais
bon du
coup on va commencer directement avec la première question qui est, est-ce que
c'est
réaliste ? Est-ce que c'est réaliste ? Et ça c'est typiquement l'exemple, c'est
que dans la série en fait, avec son entreprise, ils disent « ah tu vas te
trouver une chambre
de bonne ». Une chambre de bonne, c'est les chambres sous les toits de Paris, et
c'est
connu pour être des appartements étudiants ou des appartements pas chers, mais
très
petits, enfin quand même chers pour la taille, mais des appartements très très
petits.
Et en gros donc dans la série, ils commencent à dire « chambre de bonne ». Et là
en
fait, elle arrive dans la série, elle arrive dans un appartement qui est
franchement tout
sauf une chambre de bonne, l'appartement est grand.
C'est limite l'appartement qu'on avait quand on était à Paris, le premier
appartement.
Même le deuxième, notre premier appartement, il était plus petit que son
C'est loin d'être une chambre de bonne.
Oui, ce n'est pas une chambre de bonne. Je ne suis pas jaloux de l'appartement
de
Emily. Mais disons que quand j'étais en stage, j'ai habité dans une chambre
bonne, et c'est 15 mètres carrés. Quand vous allez aux toilettes, déjà des fois
les
toilettes sont à l'extérieur de l'appartement et c'est des toilettes communes à
plusieurs
appartements. Moi j'avais la chance d'avoir mes propres toilettes, mais disons
que je
ne pouvais pas fermer la porte des toilettes, enfin mes genoux étaient trop
longs pour la
porte. Et souvent on fait des blagues, enfin les Français font les blagues. Oui,
dans mon
appartement je peux aller aux toilettes, faire la vaisselle, me doucher et
dormir tout ça
dans la même pièce. Donc c'est pour dire que c'est des trucs très petits. Mais
voilà,
c'est vrai que son appartement est quand même très grand.
Pour une personne seule il est cool en vrai. Je pense que nous notre deuxième
appartement
à Paris, il faisait 44 mètres carrés. Oui mais là elle n'a pas de chambre quand
même.
Elle n'a pas de chambre. Mais comment parce qu'à un moment sa copine, elle dorme
dans
le même lit. Ok, bon.
C'est un studio, c'est pas une chambre de bonne mais c'est un studio. C'est un grand studio.
Mais disons
que au niveau de la taille je pense que son appartement il fait 44 mètres carrés
et pour
vous dire c'est de l'ordre de... Il faut compter au moins avant, avant c'était
moins
cher je pense. Mais aujourd'hui il faut compter au moins 1200 euros je pense.
Mais vous voyez
là, bon déjà on parle de l'appartement depuis cinq minutes. C'est un peu les
débats
qu'il y avait sur les réseaux sociaux français qui disaient non mais de toute
façon c'est
pas réaliste etc. Le truc réaliste c'est l'appartement au sixième étage sans
ascenseur.
Oui ça. C'est des vieux bâtiments à Paris donc forcément enfin c'est pas tout
le temps
qu'il y a des ascenseurs quoi. Oui du coup ça pareil ... Moi j'ai eu un
appartement
où il n'y avait pas d'ascenseur sixième étage et donc il vaut mieux ne pas
oublier
quelque chose quand vous sortez ou ce genre de choses. Donc voilà bon, on a
parlé de
l'appartement gate mais après c'est vrai que toute la série en fait c'est tout
est
dans les beaux quartiers et en fait la réponse c'est presque la série est
réaliste si vous
êtes très riche. C'est un peu ça ? Oui après je ne trouve pas qu'elle vive comme
une personne ultra riche. C'est niveau fringue etc oui bien sûr mais bon c'est
une série.
Son appartement il est abordable j'imagine. Après elle ne fait pas des folies
quoi. Oui
mais il y a le côté quand même où du coup elle côtoie que des choses riche. Oui
bah
elle travaille dans un truc de luxe. Elle travaille dans un truc de luxe ça va
dans
les événements des événements super stylés. Ça fait riche mais c'est son taff.
Oui elle
ne paye rien quoi. Mais par exemple le restaurant de son ami qui a un restaurant
étoilé. Oui
elle y va bon on sait pas. On va partir du principe qu'il l'invite à chaque
fois. Oui
mais si tu vas dans un étoilé tous les soirs. Non oui c'est pas possible. C'est
un budget
restaurant quand même. Ah bah oui. Mais du coup oui il y a cette dimension où
c'est
en fait c'est forcément c'est pas une critique mais c'est très romancé c'est à
dire qu'elle
a le travail parfait et elle va tous les événements super stylés quand vous êtes
fan de mode de luxe etc. Moi ce que je trouve réaliste c'est enfin du
coup je ne suis pas étrangère donc je ne m'en rends pas forcément compte mais
par
exemple quand je ne sais pas pourquoi quand j'ai vu ce passage j'ai eu
l'impression
de l'avoir déjà vécu alors que je parle français quoi normalement mais la
boulangère
qui la reprend sur comment elle parle et au final on a l'impression que la
est pas sympa mais il faut juste apprendre à la connaître. Oui et ça c'est super
important
parce que souvent les étrangers disent que quand ils sont à Paris et qu'ils
essaient
de parler français, on les reprend, les gens sont super désagréables et ils
corrigent
ce qu'ils disent comme s'ils étaient énervés des fautes de français. Je pense
que c'est
vraiment pour aider et que les français ne sont sûrement pas les personnes les
plus
expressives mais si vous vous trompez sur le genre de quelque chose si vous
dites le maison
au lieu de la maison et qu'une personne française vous dit non on dit la maison,
il ne faut pas
le prendre mal je pense que c'est vraiment plus un côté j'ai envie de t'aider
pour
mieux parler français et ce n'est pas du tout en mode tu ne respectes pas ma
langue
etc. Et ça c'est vrai qu'on le voit bien parce que dans le premier épisode ou
dans
un des premiers épisodes la boulangère lui fait une réflexion comme ça dans un
style
un peu désagréable mais un style français on va dire et plus tard dans la série
on
voit que maintenant elles s'entendent bien parce qu'elles ont appris à se
connaître.
C'est pas qu'on n'est pas sympa c'est juste qu'il faut un petit peu. Après il y
a des
gens qui sont désagréables quand même. Bien sûr mais dans toutes les grandes
villes
surtout. Oui et puis surtout si tu vas dans l'endroit hyper touristique où c'est
un restaurant où les gens ils ont énormément de travail ils voient des étrangers
de toute
la journée ils souvent ils sont désagréables. Mais peut-être que nous on le serait
aussi si
on était à leur place. Oui mais en tout cas ce truc de corriger ce n'est pas
forcément
quelque chose de mauvais et ça je le vois souvent sur les réseaux sociaux donc
voilà
je voulais juste parler de ça. Il y a ça il y a la boulangère et qu'est ce qu'il
y
a d'autres. Attends il y avait une truc aussi. Oui
parce qu'au début de la série enfin je reviens sur ça mais au début de la série
je ne sais pas si ça avait trop regardé. Non j'ai pas regardé le début parce
qu'au
début elle a commencé à regarder toute seule et j'ai commencé j'ai rejoint
l'aventure
plus tard. Parce qu'en fait au début tous ses collègues
ils sont vraiment désag' et du coup ils sont vraiment désagréables.
Désag' c'est... Pardon et du coup c'est vraiment enfin ça a rejoint un peu
parce
que vers la fin on se rend compte qu'ils sont juste normaux quoi c'est juste que
enfin je sais pas ils dépeignent un portrait vraiment pas sympa des français.
Oui il y a cette représentation des français qui ne sont pas agréables mais ça
je pense
que c'est juste l'écart qu'il y a entre les français et les américains et là
encore
une fois c'est juste pour expliquer ce n'est pas mieux ou moins bien mais je
pense que
les américains par exemple sont beaucoup plus outgoing enfin beaucoup plus
avenant
et beaucoup plus friendly dès le début alors qu'en France ce n'est pas du tout
le
cas et du coup c'est vrai qu'un français ou quand vous rencontrez quelqu'un qui
est
très... Non qui est très à l'américaine en mode "ah comment tu vas, oh c'est le
plus beau manteau que j'ai jamais" c'est vraiment la personne la plus stylée que
je connaisse. Dans ces cas là les français ils vont
être en mode "qu'est-ce qu'il me veut, il va me demander quelque chose" et du
coup
je comprends que si on fait le chemin inverse quand vous êtes un américain et
que vous
arrivez et que les français paraissent très désagréables vous pouvez avoir
l'impression
d'avoir fait quelque chose de mal ou que les personnes ne sont vraiment pas du
tout
agréables mais je pense que c'est juste culturel parce que si vous devenez ami
avec
un français je pense que vous pouvez enfin si si un français devient très
agréable
avec vous il y a de fortes chances qu'il vous considère comme son ami en quelque
sorte alors que pour un français aux états-unis par exemple c'est peut-être plus
difficile
à comprendre, à savoir parce que par exemple du coup si tu as une interaction si
tu parles
avec quelqu'un et qu'il est super friendly etc tu te dis mais en fait cette
personne
m'adore alors qu'au final peut-être que c'est juste de la politesse ou juste
culturelement
c'est comme ça quoi et donc ça le fait qu'au début dans l'agence ils sont pas
ils sont pas sympa ils sont désagréables je pense qu'il joue un peu sur ce
cliché
parce que c'est pareil la big boss donc Sylvie, Sylvie elle a toujours ce rôle
désagréable
mais au fond tu sais qu'elle aime bien Émilie quoi donc voilà mais du coup bon
c'est
une bonne transition pour les points positifs je trouve que les points positifs
c'est les
personnages qui sont marrants, moi mon personnage préféré c'est Luc qui est le
grand fin,
le romantique, le cliché je pense parisien un peu old school et qui est un peu
tête
en l'air qui est un peu rêveur et il y a la scène où ça c'est une scène je pense
que c'est une scène très réaliste française où il prend son vélo il part il est
à deux
doigts de rentrer dans quelqu'un d'avoir un accident et là il s'insulte les deux
il fait mais qu'est-ce tu fais connard je sais pas quoi vraiment il s'insulte
très
fort et juste après il se retourne il fait à la prochaine un peu en mode comme
si ça
n'avait aucune importance de ce oui c'est genre normal quoi c'est le quotidien
et ça
ça m'avait fait ça quand on était allés au japon on était allés au japon le
japon
ils sont très polis etc j'étais rentré en france j'étais allé au travail à vélo
donc j'étais dans paris à vélo et là j'entendais des ... bon je vais le dire mais
c'est j'entendais
des gens qui s'engueulaient j'ai entendu un mec crier "fils de ***" je sais pas bon
je mettrai
un bip ou je serais démonétisé mais du coup c'est vrai que c'est vrai que c'est
vrai
qu'il y a un peu on s'engueule facilement enfin à paris surtout après ça dépend
des
gens parce que moi je ne supporte pas m'engueuler avec les gens oui oui mais il
ya des gens agressifs
où voilà il ya facilement des insultes mais du coup ça c'était une une scène
assez drôle
les personnages donc il y a Luc, ll y a Sylvie bien sûr qu'est la big boss qui est
la pure parisienne
la queen la queen la reine il ya qui d'autre donc bon il ya antoine dans le rôle du nez
donc la personne qui travaille dans les parfums qui est sympa et après il ya il
ya gabriel il ya
gabriel aussi qui est un français pas le meilleur perso je trouve il ya Mindy
qui est je pense que
elle représente la pure américaine enfin de notre point de vue français ça fait
très américaine
justement outgoing etc et voilà après il y a Marcello qui est le vrai italien
donc ouais c'est
vrai que les personnages il y en a il y en a pas mal et ils sont de manière
générale ils sont
tous des clichés ambulant ouais finalement oui ils sont tous très clichés mais
du coup
il n'y a pas de chacun en prend un peu pour son grade quoi oui enfin je veux
dire il n'y a pas de
préférence du coup c'est marrant ouais et après c'est du coup vu que les
personnages sont assez
clichés ça se regarde quand même très facilement c'est pas enfin c'est très
divertissant quoi ouais
c'est juste je trouvais que la dernière saison et toi je pense pareil tout
s'enchaîne trop vite
bah alors sur l'avant dernière chez plus ouais mais ça c'est plus dans les
points négatifs là
on est dans les points positifs la structure de ma vidéo Justine pardon non
ouais du coup c'est
vrai que bon comme il y a plein de personnages très clichés plus les ils sont
tous tous pardon
plus clichés les uns que les autres et du coup ça crée des histoires et ouais ça
se regarde
très facilement ça se binge watch assez rapidement c'est le créateur de Sex and the
city ok
et du coup j'imagine je n'ai pas regardé mais j'imagine que c'est un peu le même
style de série
oui mais c'est quand même plus fin Sex and the city c'est moins cul-cul je sais pas comment dire et du
coup Sex and the city c'est la même chose c'est la vie à new york en étant riche oui
certes parce que
je pense que du coup je sais pas comment les américains voient Sex and the city mais
du coup les
français je pense qu'ils regardent Sex and the city on se dit mais la vie à new york
ça doit être
génial non on se dit pas ça on n'est pas stupides mais oui mais bon ils ont tous
des appartes immenses
etc. ouais et puis elles sont trop stylés elles sont trop trop bien enfin bref du
coup ouais c'est vrai
que bon je pense que c'est la personne qui fait la série darren star il connaît
son travail je pense
que voilà il sait faire des bonnes séries mais du coup ouais pour passer au
point négatif donc
tu disais tout va très vite dans le dernier et j'ai plus remarqué ça genre bah
c'est peut-être
la saison ils sont à rome ouais genre t'as l'impression elle va rester à rome et
au bout de
quatre épisodes elle se casse ... ça du coup moi c'est un peu la critique que j'ai à faire c'est que c'est du
coup c'est très répétitif et ce truc de rome c'est une excuse pour essayer de
faire quelque chose
d'original mais finalement, mais finalement ça reste très répétitif et du
coup ils accélèrent
sûrement un peu le rythme mais bon au bout d'un moment c'est toujours la même
chose quoi c'est en
fait c'est pareil les donc il y a les grosso modo une grosse partie du scénario
c'est les histoires
d'amour entre les personnages et globalement en fait tout le monde tombe
amoureux de tout
le monde et il y en a ils viennent ils repartent ils reviennent et en
fait ça fait un peu
une boucle infinie où du coup rien n'est stable et tu sais que rien n'est stable
parce que il faut
qu'il y ait de l'animation il faut de l'animation pour que la série soit
intéressante mais du
coup au bout d'un moment en fait ça perd un peu de son sens oui parce que
l'histoire avec Camille
gabriel et la quand ils sont au ski et tout c'est un peu n'importe quoi ouais c'est en
fait quand tu
quand tout commence à aller bien tu te dis bon il va y avoir un problème
obligatoirement parce que
émilie ne sait pas avoir une relation saine et durable non mais non mais quand
elle aime un mec
et que elle est avec lui après d'un coup il se passe quelque chose et elle tombe
amoureux d'un
d'un autre d'un autre etc mais son son amour pour la vie on sait qui c'est un un
moment non
enfin un moment c'est un peu bizarre mais du coup c'est vrai que oui c'est vrai
qu'on sait pas
trop c'est vrai qu'au début c'est très divertissant mais qu'au bout d'un moment
tu te dis bon
ben en fait tout ça ça ne sert à rien puisque à la fin ça ne va pas durer je
sais pas comment
dire mais tu sais qui va se passer 10 000 trucs oui et que disons qu'en plus on
n'a aucun repère
dans le temps sur la série ouais il n'y a pas les saisons genre ouais il y a un
Noël ouais voilà
il y a un Noël et elle rentre jamais chez elle aux états unis son vol a été
annulé elle se retrouve
au ski chez camille et là patatra mais oui et d'ailleurs on la voit plus après
camille ouais
non mais voilà du coup c'est vrai que là il va y avoir une nouvelle saison qui
va sortir je sais pas
quand je sais pas quand mais c'est vrai que ça fait du bien de faire une pause
avant la prochaine
saison quoi parce qu'à force elle tombe amoureux de quelqu'un ça va bien se
passer et au final
ça se passe mal et c'est pareil avec tous les personnages toutes les histoires
Sylvie avec son
mari c'est pareil à un moment ils sont ils sont amoureux ils se manquent
terriblement juste après
bah forcément il y a une il y a un problème etc etc tout se passe comme ça
pareil avec l'agence
avec le travail à un moment ça se passe super bien juste après ça se passe très
mal après ça se
repasse très bien etc et c'est vrai que du coup ça fait un peu un cycle infini
où au bout d'un moment
on se dit bon on a un peu compris la mécanique et mais en fait je sais pas s'ils
arriveraient à
faire quelque chose de divertissant d'intéressant sans toutes ces histoires quoi
bah ils sont obligés non
je vois pas ce que il pourrait faire de mieux bah quand on disait que c'était un
peu cul-cul c'est
que justement toutes ces histoires ça reste très ça reste un peu superficiel
quoi et est ce
qu'il pourrait pas faire des choses un peu plus profondes un peu plus deep des
histoires entre les
personnages un peu plus sérieuses on va dire que juste que juste il a couché avec
lui oh il est
est amoureux d'elle oh il l'a trompé etc tu vois je ne sais pas quoi répondre je
comprends oui
j'acquiesce ouais j'ai mal au dos tu veux montrer à la caméra ce que t'as fait
c'est des personnages
là c'est la tête et en fait ça va être des ebi fry c'est t'sais les crevettes
frites ouais
donc c'est un plat japonais oui c'est des petits personnages mais du coup ça
après c'est tu les
fais cuire dans le four oui et tu les vernis oui ça tienne bien ouais et pour
les vendre comme des
porte-clés dans les conventions ouais ou en ligne ouais tu vas faim ok bon on va
arrêter le podcast
là de toute façon je pense que je pense que on peut pas on peut pas faire
beaucoup plus c'est
pas non et puis moi je suis pas critique de film non mais les gens ils vont
regarder le podcast
pour dire qu'en voyant que je suis pas très pourtant t'as un t-shirt jurassic
park oui alors
ça j'adore par contre je suis fan si s'il pouvait mettre des dinosaures dans
Emily in paris ça serait
l'idéal non mais voilà du coup c'était juste voilà pour vous donner notre avis
et t'façon
on verra la prochaine saison j'espère que vous avez aimé ce podcast en mode ... dîtes nous si
vous avez regardé
aussi ouais dites nous ce que vous avez pensé de la série en commentaire c'est
sûrement un podcast
plus difficile parce qu'on est deux à parler et on parle plus rapidement mais
voilà si ça vous
intéresse de voir plus de choses comme ça n'hésitez pas à me le dire dans les
commentaires le script
sera sur patreon donc vous pouvez vous pourrez y accéder gratuitement et voilà
merci à la prochaine